let's try 774 774 sometimes local to
Massachusetts go ahead 774 Oh
Massachusetts all right go ahead
yeah um I was uh I'm to wonder about a
policy said calling for a ban on
bulletins it would be different classes
of gum okay isn't an ACEF in a class of
gun in a sense I mean it's a
categorization right yes so I mean like
so just like you have like certain
classes further like 18-wheelers right
so a fire like an alert experience okay
so how would you classify them um well I
mean it would you know kind of like
automatics you know there was illegal to
shoot more rounds but isn't that already
like art these are yo pat-pat you're
struggling over there isn't aren't these
isn't this how guns are already
classified like you've got semi-auto and
you've got automatic you've got assault
weapons you have handgun like aren't
these already the classifications yeah
and I mean I'm saying that they're more
they're more they cause more damage than
regular handguns right but as far as I
know they do yeah automatic scan gloves
more damage sure yeah something in place
of a of a pin it would have separate
classes of ways and things so oh I see
so just because you get your permit that
lets you have a handgun does not
automatically allow you to have an
automatic weapon a semi-automatic weapon
whatever yes so I'm saying like
employment take away from the narrative
bleaker for banning like kind of
standing guns right to have to just
require more experience in training
right I don't think it's a bad idea I
think that there's something interesting
too that I think that you will very
quickly come up against the exact the
right the pro-gun right will make the
same argument no matter how you want to
slice and dice it they'll still say it
is an imposition and an unfair one at
that it is going against free and open
gun owner
ship as per that like I I think it's an
interesting idea and I think it's
logical that the more damage that could
be done in a short amount of time with a
firearm the more training that should be
required and I would argue insurance to
have that gun I totally agree with you I
just think you're gonna have the exact
same problems that we already have now
passing just universal background checks
yeah but I do think they'll make it kind
of like a tougher case to make cuz I'm
we can just say that you know we're just
requiring work during the training okay
yeah I agree I don't disagree yeah yeah
yeah interesting idea thank you so much
appreciate the call always good to hear
from folks in Massachusetts